the arrest of three alleged white
supremacists is raising alarms ahead of
a gun rights rally in Richmond Virginia
the state's governor says there is
credible intelligence of potential
violence at Monday's event depa gazes in
Richmond outside of the Capitol Jeff who
are these men
well good morning here at the Capitol
you can see these temporary fences here
behind me in place they put in place
they've been put in place for crowd
control on Monday a security measure
just in case the rest of the three men
Michelle is really feeding this
narrative that there could be violence
here on Monday in fact investigators say
the three men were targeting the event
as a way of spreading their hate filled
ideology images presented in court
Thursday paint a picture of a group
preparing for battle long guns and some
appearing to wear fatigues one of the
men Patrick Matthews is a Canadian Army
veteran who is said to be an explosives
expert American Brian Laemmle jr. is an
Army veteran who served in Iraq the
third suspect is American William bill
bro
the men are alleged members of the base
a neo-nazi group that advocates violence
against minorities while rallying around
slogans like savior race investigators
allege the men had built a functioning
assault rifle and had recently bought
more than 1500 rounds of ammunition
attorney Robert bonza Brep resents
Bilborough I was just appointed to
represent this fine young man
he's a 19 year old young man with no
prior record the arrests only reinforced
concerns Monday's rally could be a
repeat of what happened in
Charlottesville in 2017 unless officials
intervene governor Ralph Northam
temporary ban on all weapons near
Capitol grounds withstood a legal
challenge on Thursday Monday's rally is
related to new gun reforms proposed in
Virginia's legislature now controlled by
Democrats for the first time in more
than two decades that include universal
background checks and a once a month
limit on handgun purchases are you
concerned that it could escalate into
something that you didn't expect it's
always possible that that could happen
like rally organizer Phillip Van Cleve
refuses to call off the event / the
arrests will not let them
for us or slow us down we were trying to
protect rights here in court prosecutors
said that one of the men talked about
traveling to Ukraine to fight and
compared the base to al-qaida
investigators also say the Canadian man
who was arrested was here in this
country illegally Tony see what happens
Monday Jeff thank you very much